do you think about
the end of this ride our mortality do
you think about your death
i do oh particularly i'm going to have
um
a heart valve replacement in about seven
days where
i could could not make it you know it's
a very serious operation and i think
about that
very much and um
i asked for peace i just lost my brother
about 10 days ago
so unexpectedly and that really
put you know makes you think of your
mortality
are you afraid um somewhat and some
and and yet not
yeah i want to live lex i want to live
you know this life is fun yes
do you think about your death roger i
have visions
i visions and they often happen very
very clear
like what i have seen in the future
scientists might call it wormholes or
and the old testament they call it
prophets but i i see sometimes into the
future
around the corner it's clear as we're
sitting right here what's that look like
i was on a porch and i believe i was in
like central america place
i was an old man with khaki pants and a
white shirt
and this it was a chair with a wide arms
and it was straight
and there's like the beams coming out
above my head and i'm on the porch
spoken video and uh and i uh
i come i i have out of the body
experiences also
and i came out of my body just i just
floated out of my body
and went into a veil and like into a
mist
and i believe that's probably why it
happened you talk about
you talk about like it's in your past
this is your favorite now this isn't my
future
but this is something he has seen in the
yeah no i know but it's funny just yeah
the tents you use
it happened and yet it's something that
will happen
yeah true both are true it's just
unbelievable that and i
i i don't know how many people have it
but i have it i walked out of my body
just like
just where i could come up to you and
look and set up on the radio i used to
be at work on the railroad and i i had
them there how do you explain that
what the heck is going on in this
universe that's that's possible
oh i don't know but uh certainly
certainly a phenomenon which it happened
and uh there's a guy bill monroe that
wrote the book only out of the body he
tells about it
and who is the guy that writes uh
the alchemist
he has them also just like that and and
uh he tells about how it happens on him
might happen differently
and but you certainly can come out of
your body
what do you think the meaning of uh this
life is
maybe from from from your faith
but also from just the amazing adventure
that you lived through
how do you make sense of why the heck
we're here
i don't know it just it's just kind of
like who you are even when i was a child
i was like
i'm different from other people
you know and just as a boy i was like i
uh
i don't know could you put into words
how you were different or was just a few
yeah like my brother i mean he kept his
hands clean and his shoes shine and
here i was barefooted catching a wild
hog or a wrestling a
a horse trying to get it down you know i
saw pictures of you climbing a tree
recently when i first got out of prison
always something like that
yeah i just so i don't know it's just
that
uh and i noticed that
something about me is sometimes in
prison there'd be a knife fight
and people just you see them rough guys
that
turn white from it it i just kind of
almost like smile i mean
unless if they come at me up turn white
and get away but it doesn't
bother those things like something
bothered me i just prison didn't bother
me
so you don't know what the heck the
meaning is you just know you're a bit
different
than the others yeah it might be and
then maybe
well um maybe the the whole point is you
want to realize you want to let that
madness flourish that uniqueness
flourish
that's the whole point of life we're all
different in our in like
very interesting little ways yes and the
more different you are you want to let
that
you want to let that become you want to
let it be it's full
it's like a garden you know all the
different flowers yeah
you did mention um you weren't sure if
there's a free will or not
um do you think it's all predetermined
or do you think we make our own choices
to make our decisions i just said if it
is i hope that
but i know that we make our decisions
yes and i agree
and i i know that we are spirits that
are living in this
in this flesh that's beyond the shadow
of a doubt with me
if you walk out of your body and have
out of body experience you will know it
so the body is just the temporary the
spirit lives on
eternally with no beginning and no end
it just
and that's hard to fathom yeah this is
just a little this is a shell
to contain that spirit you know this is
the way we work on earth you know
but yeah i know i'm an eternal being
so are you do you think there's a why to
it
you know do you think there's a meaning
to this life well i think the why is
beyond
my capability of understanding it's
someone greater
than me i don't understand it but
it's awesome i just know that it's
awesome
and one day we will know the answers
once we get to that
cross over the other to the other side i
think we will understand
clearly it says you know now we see
through a glass darkly
but then when we are face to face with
god we will understand
and uh until we know let's just enjoy
this beautiful life yes oh we got it
i love everybody and everything i do
and it's just and i'm sorry if i put a
stumbling block in anybody's way
i wouldn't want to but uh these are
these things and i just think about oh
what a
hypocritical world we live in though
like uh almost anybody out there listen
okay he's the drug dealer
and i would say most of them are
committed to adultery that's a cardinal
sin
and yet they moved through throw rocks
at me for moving uh
uh marijuana cocaine across the road
yeah
it's just if you saw the two different
things you'd say what a
terrible difference it is but we become
conditioned with
this mad society that we have
you